on today's visual studio toolbox Jeffery
will show us why Visual Studio code is
the place to be for data science and
Python hi welcome to visual studio
toolbox I'm your host Robert Greene and
joining me today is Jeffrey mu hey
Jeffrey hey Robert thanks for coming on
the show yeah no problem Jeffrey is a
program manager in the Python tools
group at Microsoft and so this is kind
of our part two of our Python series we
had tarik on in the previous episode to
give us kind of an overview of Python
and today you're gonna focus on data
science
yeah for sure so what does that mean
yeah so why data science
well data science is one of the biggest
workloads in Python right now we're
estimating around like 30 35 % of all
Python developers do data size on some
sort so like everyone's trying to do
optimized for data science python as a
language or is it more of a
general-purpose thing well the reason
why I python so popular for data science
is because it's such a like easy to pick
up language to learn so a lot of these
data Sciences don't have this
engineering background so it's really
easy for them to like plug and play and
like minimal learning curve and okay
it's the it's kind of like almost a
defect of what people use in the
industry okay
but yeah so the reason they because data
science is so popular we want to have it
like a first-class data science
experience inside BS code and then most
data scientists use Jupiter notebooks
which is a tool that people used to
explore or develop code and because of
this we want to have Visual Studio code
we want to offer first-class experience
inside it for data science and also for
developing with Jupiter notebooks as
well so our team has been cooking up
like a lot of really cool new features
in the past month this just like
released this month as well so I'm super
excited to be here to show you what we
have to offer all the cool things we can
do with data science inside Visual
Studio as well cool yeah so I guess to
get started before I guess before we get
started if you're interested in just
general Python as well or like something
like web application or web development
vs code you can check out my colleague
Tye week's video like you mentioned
earlier he also has a video on channel 9
as well okay also so akms /v sd4 slash
python vs code
which is some getting started and then
there was a whole series on Python yeah
so definitely go check forgot to mention
on-air in the last episode so we'll make
up for that now all right
data science yep so it's easy if you've
never heard of BS code before it's
completely open-source it's free it's
actually really easy to transition your
Jupiter notebooks from your other
editors or ideas into vs code because we
now offer a fully functional Jupiter UI
inside vs code and also a fully
functional duper hotkeys as well so it's
really easy to just bring a jupiter
notebook in or create a new one there's
like no learning curve you just plug and
play and it's what you expect ok so how
you can get started is first if you
don't have Visual Studio code you want
to install that from code Visual Studio
com so once you actually have Visual
Studio Visual Studio code sorry
installed it's Visual Studio code it's
actually like a bare-bones IDE so it
doesn't actually come with the data
science features you'll need to install
the Python extension on top which will
actually get you those data science
features so to do this you can go into
Visual Studio code on the left hand side
you'll see the extensions tab you can
click into it and you can search for the
keyword Python yeah and it'll be the
first one that shows up and you can
click install as you can see I already
have it installed in my machine just for
the sake of this demo ok so once you
have the Python extension and BS code
installed the last thing you'll need
actually is distribution of python in
your machine so if you don't have a
great Python in your machine you'll need
to install that and the there's two main
ways to do it
there's the download from the official
Python website or you can get an
anaconda distribution of Python which I
personally recommend and anaconda I
guess like a tldr I like it just a bit
is it's basically a package manager and
its really good for data science because
it it's really good at managing your
environments for data science and
anaconda is something that most of the
days has communities ok so I would
personally recommend that and I also
have anaconda installed on this machine
as well so the stro will go through that
as well so once you have those two
installed I guess the first thing you'll
want to do is to get started is to
create a new jupiter notebook if you
don't already have one you can also if
you already have a jupiter notebook you
can open it up normally and open it up
as well but it's for the sake of this
video we're just gonna go through the
getting started experience ok so the
first thing you'll want to do is we want
to access the command palette so let me
just close this so you can access that
through control shift P or
kamancheh Pia if you're on a Mac and
I'll bring this up
and while the command pellets so good is
because it has all the actions of yes
code listed in it so if you ever don't
remember how to get this a menu or some
action you just bring this up and search
what you need so for in our case we're
gonna create a new jupiter notebook so i
would search creates new and you'll see
one of the first things that pops up is
create a new blank jupiter notebook so
if we click on this it will open up what
we call our notebook editor which is the
new feature we have for editing jupiter
notebooks and you might be asking what's
the difference between a jupiter
notebook and a regular python file so
the main thing is that a Jupiter
notebook file you can think about it as
your code is segmented into different
sections or what we call cells whereas
in a Python file everything is all
together so what's really good with
Jupiter notebooks you can see is these
cells can be run individually so you can
run individual pieces of your code in
that file or multiple times or you don't
have to run the entire file to like see
a new output so that's where keep your
notebook is really useful because you
can just experiment and test and change
like one or two things just to see if
that makes think makes your data better
okay so now that we're in our notebook
editor we can start going through the UI
of the notebook so if we go into the
notebook ourselves we'll see when you
make a new notebook there's one
individual cell already and we can now
start going through you can see there's
like buttons and in the cell and there's
also a buttons like up top so the buns
on the seller what we call Excel level
actions there are things that will
affect the cell itself and the ones that
are up top in the toolbar what we call
like notebook or like global whiplash
and so they affect like the entire
notebook so we'll go through the in the
cell actions first so we can look on the
left there you have your move cell up
and move cell down buttons so if I only
have one cell here right now but if I
had another cell below I can just click
on this button and move the cell below
that to the right of that we have our
execution counter so what that does is
they'll tell you the relative when the
cell was running in comparison to all
the other cells so I have a number of
like let's say 1 2 or 3 right now I
haven't I don't have the cell run yet so
there's no number beside it below that
we have our Run button so let's say I
have write some code prints hi you can
just click that Run button and I'll
execute that cell so we'll see the word
high and then below that we have our
cells or buttons for run cells above and
run cells below so what run cells above
does
that they'll run all your cells that are
above the current slope but not
including the current cell so where this
is really useful is let's say you have
like a lot of cells like maybe like
twenty or thirty cells that you want to
get through before you have to run the
current cell instead of having to click
that Run button all those 30 cells you
just click this one button it'll run all
those cells for you and similarly with
run cells run cell and below it'll run
the current cell and all the cells below
so it minimizes that amount of clicks
that you have to click the next one is a
switch change to mark down so with this
is Jupiter notebooks also support not
just Python as a language but also
supports the markdown syntax as a
language and markdown is basically waste
like pretty print your taxi can like
have like bold or like lists and stuff
and this is just for like commenting
your notebook and making a notebook more
readable okay and then the last one is
delete cells so you can click on that
it'll just leave the cell so now let's
go over some of these I guess overall
global actions in the notebook so at the
bottom of your notebook you'll always
have this insert cell below button so
it's really easy to always just add a
new cell below whenever you want and
then as well there's also a insert cell
above button or and sort of cell below
but adds up at the very top so only show
on hover so if you click on that you'll
see it adds the cell above right so now
let's go through the top-level toolbar
so the first to come are the your kernel
actions
so first is restarting your Python
kernel if anything happens your kernel
or if it gets into some weird state or
you ever need to be started you can just
click that click on that and will
restart your kernel next one is your
interrupt kernel so this is more like
let's say you're running some really
long code cell and it gets stuck in the
infinite loop or it's just taking like
really long time and you just want to
stop it if you're just in this button
it'll stop the execution the next one is
another insert cell button so this is it
so just insert a new cell below whatever
cell you focus so for example I have a
cell here I can click this and insert a
new cell below your next one is your run
all cells button so like the run all
above and run all below you just wanted
one all the cells in your notebook to
see the output you just click this
button instead of having to run all your
cells individually the next one is the
clear-all output so let's say you see in
this print statement I have a open of
hi-yah I can just click on this and you
move all out put in my notebook the next
one is what we call that variable
explorer so it'll show all your active
variables in your notebook currently I
don't have any variables in this
notebook so nothing shows up but later
on this video I'll show a more advanced
notebook and then go into this feature
more in-depth okay next is your save
notebook and then finally is your
convert and save to as a Python script
so this is what I was mentioning earlier
where we have a feature where you can
actually convert your Python notebook
into a Python like file and again I'll
get some more in depth of this feature
later on this vid okay so let's move on
so this is when I created a notebook
from scratch but let's say you already
have a notebook open or a notebook that
you want to bring into v/s code so for
example I have this data science in
school notebook which it is but let's
open that up and you can see that it
also opens up in our notebook editor as
well so this is a notebook I already
have you can see that the outputs are
already saved so if I if you already
have that notebook the output save them
externally from another notebook
application I'll also save that in this
one and some things that we can go
through our there's full support for
intellisense in the Teleco so as you can
see here let's say I remove this
statement if I don't want to write
Splott dot show you can see
IntelliChoice up with a suggestion for
show and there's also an intellisense
for all the api that support it so if I
want to do this and you can see that
there's a it also shows a function
signature of what show does so PLT comes
from matplotlib pi plot so matplotlib is
a one of the most popular plotting
libraries for data science so it's
really good for just graphing and seeing
what okay yep seeing your data so I
guess the first feature I want to go
through more in depth is our call our
plot viewer so you can see here that
this cell generated a plot as an output
and you can see that there's like a lot
of data it's kind of hard to sleep zoom
in it's like the plots kind of small so
it's hard to see the data really clearly
so we can actually do is if you click on
this top left button here it brings up
the plot viewer in a new window and then
this plot viewer will actually
bring up a bigger image of that plot and
then you can do really cool things such
as you can zoom into the plot so let's
say you want to like look closer at
where it crosses the x-axis you can see
here it also lets you do other cool
things such as you can save the plot in
different formats so if you want to save
as like a PDF or PNG as an image and you
want to share with other people you can
do that as well so now let's go back to
our notebook our other cool feature that
I mentioned before was the variable
Explorer so with the variable Explorer
let's I open that I just ran this code
cell and you can see that P shows up
because P isn't a variable I just made
so with the variable Explorer it'll show
up you're at the current state of all
your variables and where this is really
useful is let's say you have like many
cells that you run and maybe sometimes
you run them out of order because you
want to like fix some code in it and
were you running it again and many times
you won't know oh what's like I don't
remember what my variable was or like I
don't remember the state and you have to
print that out but the variable Explorer
is really useful because you can just
open it up and you'll see at a glance
exactly what your variables are okay so
the variable Explorer it I'll have the
name of the variable so in this case we
have P they'll have the type of the
variable so we have an ND array type
will have a count which is basically
like the length of the variable so we
have a size 100 here and it shows up 100
but the most really interesting part is
the value so this is really useful for
datasets and this also ties into our new
feature called
the data viewer so if you look on the
right there's a button over here for
array or indeed array types your data
frame types so say show variables and
data beer I said if you just click on
this it'll open up a new window and it
gives like an Excel like excel like
interface with all your data and this is
really useful because it lets you
basically sanity check or look at your
data set without having to write code to
do it it just works for you and even
more useful is let's say you want to do
a sanity check and you want to make sure
there's nothing like negative or no
numbers are like less than 1 or see how
many values of that all you need to do
is click this filter rows button and
you'll see this text box pop up but you
can do those text boxes let's say I want
to make sure that none of my values are
negative all I have to do is type less
than zero and I can see oh there's
nothing matching that cool or if I want
to say everything less than one Oh give
me
all these values less than one so that
was the data viewer the next thing I
want to show you is Jupiter hockey's so
like I mentioned Jupiter hockey's
basically can make your workload more
productive so instead of having to click
for all these actions or like find them
in the menus you can just do a bunch of
like hotkeys and we have full support
for many Jupiter hotkeys so for example
I went through like there's control
sorry there's shift enter so if I run it
it'll run this cell there's also if I go
into command mode I can push escape
you'll see this turn blue and then I can
also navigate between my different cells
and then if I want as well
I can push D D to delete there we go and
then for a full list of Jupiter hotkeys
you can check out at the end of this
video or in the description I'll have a
link to our documentation and it's like
a lot more hotkey supporters as well the
next thing I want to go through is a
remote Jupiter server so right now I'm
running on my laptop right here it's
pretty fast but obviously not as fast as
like like some server in the cloud area
so and with a lot of machine learning
tasks or data science tasks it's really
compute intensive so I don't want to sit
here for like maybe a few days or like
even a week waiting for like it's a run
on my machine right so we have the
ability to actually connect to a remote
server remote Jupiter server and
leverage the compute power of that so to
do this we just go back to the command
palette so control shift V or command
Shafi if you're on a Mac and will search
for the command specify Jupiter server
URI so we'll see that show up and all
you need to do is just click it and
you'll see by default it's running the
local Jupiter server so right now it's
just running on my local machine but if
you have a remote machine in the cloud
you want to leverage that compute power
of like a GPU or a really powerful CPU
you just click on this button and here
you can enter the URL for whatever
whatever server it is so that's really
useful too and also this entire
interface also supports remote SSH with
what Visual Studio code as well so you
can also connect to remote server
through that way so the last thing I
want to show you is like I mentioned
previously is the convert and saved to a
Python script so in this scenario let's
say I'm like pretty happy with what
done so far in my notebook these are
generating the right plots the code
seems right and now I want to convert it
into like a production service so it's
like an API others can use it or if I
want to convert it's like a Python
script so that people can just run it
from the command line I don't have to
have like a jupiter-like to do it well
all we have to do is just click this one
button and they'll automatically convert
all my notebook code into Python code
into a Python format so before I would
have had to manually copy and paste all
the code in the cells into a new file in
that let's say you have like a huge
notebook of like hundreds of cells that
could take like an hour something but
this makes it almost instant and we can
see that we can see lovely good the
other direction if you have this Python
yeah for sure I'm back to a Jupiter
notebook mm-hmm so there's a also a
feature that we have that lets you go
the other way okay so it's like a really
binary way where you can just go from
one to the other you can work in
whatever you're comfortable in and we
want to make encourage that flexibility
as well so once you actually convert it
to a Python convert and save as a Python
file it will open up in what we call our
Python interactive window and you might
be asking what's the difference between
our notebook editor our Python
interactive window or even like let's
say our traditional just regular Python
file well the main difference is that
the jupiter our notebook editor is
mostly for jupiter notebook files so
with this extension i py and b and it
gives that traditional pipe on in sorry
a jupiter notebook interface where you
have them cells your input and output
are in line and just like the general
jupiter UI well in our python
interactive window here we'll see that
it's kind of like a hybrid of your
traditional like python file and also
the jupiter our notebook editor so
you'll see it's like a python file but
you also have i'm overlay for our
jupiter notebook cells because i know it
came from a jupiter notebook so you'll
see like these run cells run below debug
cells so you kind of have like the best
of both worlds in this case and what's
really cool is you can also let's just
save this file real quick first so let's
name it
I already have one that's test so let's
name it test one pi so with this Python
interactive window you have the benefits
of both it's like a hybrid of both
regular Python file editor and also our
notebook editor so you can see this
isn't a traditional Python file with the
test py and but we also have our
overlays for our jupiter notebooks so we
can see that this run cell run above and
debug cell and where this is really cool
as you can still runs individual code
cells like they were a jupiter notebook
but you also can run the entire file
like it was a right away python file so
you have the best of both worlds in the
villain arial and what's even cooler is
because it's a python file now we have
also the ability to debug cells so
instead of having to debug the entire
file or running and debugging their code
for the entire file you can just run for
the individual cell so if i want to
click if i want to debug the cell for
example i I can just click debug so it
can see it starts step being cool yeah
it starts stepping through the cell line
by line and if I want to like go through
each bug sorry if I want to go through
each line of code I can just click step
over and you'll see you'll see it keeps
on going through each line of code and
you can see the variables and the call
stack update as well cool yeah so the
last feature I want to go through is the
Python interactive window is the input
so we have a fully functional ipython
rebel window at the bottom right and
here you can actually type in code and
run it in line with your existing Python
file as well so and this window also has
full intellisense and telecare
capability so house context of what you
run previously and you can run that to
update your current state so for example
here I've run the cell so it has context
of like numpy pandas and matplotlib and
here I can for example create a new
variable let's name it X and I'll make
an array of zeros just as an example so
I can say zeros and then let's just make
it size 10 and then we can see that runs
as well cool yeah so those were as you
can see like my entire data science
workflow of from getting started to
create a new notebook to even just bring
my own notebook into vs code and then
doing the experimentation doing the
debugging all that was done inside just
this one tool of Visual Studio code so
that's what I think our tool will excel
in where everything you don't have to
switch between different tools
everything can just be done this one
really amazing tool it's fantastic and
yeah and this recently just came out
this month so this
all brand-new and I'm encourage everyone
to go try it out for themselves all you
have to do is download Visual Studio
code the Python extension as well and
then just bring your own notebook or
I'll create a new notebook and explore
for yourself awesome yeah alright thanks
for showing us that yeah thank you so
much for having me here
so anybody doing Python data science
Jupiter notebooks this is absolutely the
idea yep
the environment of choice for surely
yeah well and then we're actually
playing to like we're putting a lover
focused on this tool so we're gonna have
a lot many features coming out in the
coming months so hopefully I'll be back
soon to demo even more absolutely yeah
all right cool all right hope you
enjoyed that and we will see you next
time on visual studio toolbox
[Music]